just last month angular 5 was released
and with it comes the new serviceworker
module that makes building progressive
web apps easier than ever before all we
need to do is set a few configuration
variables and angular will automatically
generate a serviceworker with our
production build in this video I'm going
to show you how to use the worker to
score 100 on a progressive web app on it
and I'll show you how to customize the
worker to fit the needs of your specific
application I'm going to do this by
creating my own version of hacker news
which is the gold standard for comparing
performance and usability across various
JavaScript frameworks if you're just
finding me for the first time make sure
to subscribe and for this video I have a
full working demo deployed to firebase
hosting feel free to mess around with it
and if you see anything you want to
optimize our fix send me a pull request
on github
before we get going I just want to point
out that service workers aren't
supported on all modern browsers Safari
and Microsoft edge or the main holdouts
but they should be supported in the
future at the time of this video the
serviceworker is only available in that
beta version of the angular CLI so
you'll want to install it with the next
tag and then make sure the version you
have installed is 1.6 or greater and if
you're starting from an existing angular
5 app you can simply create the files
I'm about to show you in the upcoming
steps here to create a new app with the
serviceworker configured automatically
run ng new with the serviceworker flag
then inside that new app the first place
I'm going to go is the angular CLI JSON
file inside here you'll want to add
manifest.json to the assets array we're
going to create this file manually here
in the next step then down here you'll
notice that the serviceworker option is
set to true which tells angular to
generate the serviceworker at Build time
from there you're going to create a web
app manifest in the source directory the
purpose of the manifest is to tell
browsers how to handle your web app
we're just going to set the bare minimum
options for now so we have a start URL
which is just the root and then you'll
need a theme color and background color
then you'll need to add some icons if
you want your app to be installable on
mobile devices the bare minimum is just
a 512 by 512 image but you can add
additional sizes here if you want to as
well you will want to save your images
inside the assets folder in your angular
app now really quickly I want to show
you how the serviceworker gets
registered inside the app module it will
mr. the service worker in the ng SW
worker file if the build is production
however this didn't work for me using
angularfire too so I want to show you an
alternative way to register a worker so
you can go into the main TS file then
after your applications bootstrap you
can see if the service worker is in the
browser navigator and then register your
service worker there now we're ready to
move on to the important part which is
the ng Service Worker config file this
file tells angular how to generate the
Service Worker so I want to go through
here and explain to you what all these
different options mean the first option
is index which is just the entry point
for your app and then we have an assets
group array which defines the static
assets that are going to be cached by
the Service Worker
the first asset group is called app and
the install mode is prefetch prefetch
means that the worker is going to go out
and cache all these assets right away so
essentially these are going to be all
the files that are necessary to run your
app offline so you'll notice it has all
the files that are known at build time
including our index.html entry point as
well as the various bundle files we can
also add additional external files which
is probably going to be necessary if
you're using something like angular
material you can do that by adding an
additional urls array and add the URLs
that you want to cache to it this would
be a good place for web fonts or any
other styles you get from a CDN now I'm
going to jump down to our next asset
group which this time is installed with
the Lazy strategy we're going to add the
assets directory to it and the only
difference is that it will cache these
assets only when they're actually
requested by the user in some way
through the app at this point our worker
knows how to cache all of our assets
that are known at Build time but what
happens if we receive data from an
external API for that we can use the
data groups array which has two distinct
strategies the first strategy we're
looking at here is API freshness this
strategy will always try to make a
network call for the latest and greatest
data unless it times out after 10
seconds in this case then it will
default to whatever's in the cache for
our hacker news app we're only going to
use this strategy when the user
navigates to the new URL which contains
the latest posts from hacker news you
can add your own URLs to the urls array
and then you can control the cache
behavior in that cache config object so
freshness is great when data is
constantly changing but if it doesn't
change very often
you can use the API performance strategy
the difference here is it's going to try
and use the data in the cache but if the
max age of the cache has expired then it
will go out and make another Network
call for new data data served from the
cache is going to be a lot more
performant and appear instantaneous in
the eyes of the user eventually when you
run a production build you can go into
Chrome and pull up the network tab and
you'll see that assets are served from
the serviceworker an asset from a
serviceworker only takes a few
milliseconds so it will appear
instantaneous for your users before
getting to that point though we first
need to go into the index.html file and
add a few meta tags to ensure that we
get the 100 pwace core the main things
here that we link the manifest.json file
and that we add a meta tag for our theme
color the index.html file can be thought
of as the splash page similar to the
initial loading page on a native mobile
app the typical way to handle this page
is with your app icon and possibly a
very small amount of text then the last
thing we'll do is add a no script tag to
let the user know that they need Java
Script enabled to use this app at this
point we should be able to build our app
by running ng build flag production
after that's finished we can go into the
dist folder and you'll notice a couple
extra files here we have manifest.json
and NGS W JSON which contains all of our
actual compiled configuration for the
worker if we open that up you can see
that it lists all of our version bundle
files as well as any other configuration
that we set in that main configuration
file for the worker then if we go into
the worker JavaScript file we can see
all kinds of crazy JavaScript that were
really glad we didn't have to write from
scratch when you're ready to test your
app you can go into Chrome into the
audit tab and then click perform an
audit it's going to simulate how your
app would load on a slower 3G connection
on a mobile device for a progressive web
app it's going to verify that you
register a serviceworker it's also going
to look at your manifest file as well as
a handful of other related audits
currently we're at a hundred score for
progressive web app but our performance
is only at 79 it measures performance
based on how quickly you can get the
first meaningful content on the page and
then how long it takes your page to
become interactive by the user
seventy-nine isn't a very good score
compared to other hacker news PWA s so
in the next video i'll show you how to
optimize angular to bring the score up
into the 90s if you want to start
building your own hacker news app you
can actually do it using angular fire 2
because the hacker news API is hosted on
firebase so you can achieve that by
simply installing angular fire - and
then when you initialize your app you
use that database URL that is the hacker
news endpoint if you want to build the
exact app I built here go to angular
firebase comm and I have greater detail
of the actual app source code there
that's it for the angular 5 Service
Worker module this video helped you
please like and subscribe and if you
want to take your PWA to the next level
consider becoming a pro member at
angular firebase comm you'll get a free
copy of my book as well as a whole bunch
of exclusive content thanks for watching
and I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]